Okay, did you get that working? If so, good job.
Let's go ahead and test everything. I'll show you my
solution. Here we are, fizzbuzz.html. All we had to do
is extend base.html, surround our content with the block content
and end block, and all is well. And so it's
basically the same thing that we did here in our
shopping list html. And our base html doesn't change at
all, neither do our handlers,
still rendering fizzbuzz.html and shopping_list.html.
And the benefit of this is, if I change my base template to be more exciting
and then I go to the browser. And I reload this page, we get our exclamation
marks, and if I go, get away from
fizzbuzz, we also have our exclamation marks there
as well. So, we changed one file and
then our entire website changed along with it.